[Music]
the Navajo for many decades have relied
upon the coal industry for the creation
of thousands of high paid jobs and
revenues but all of a sudden over the
last few years these mines have been
shut down because the utility company's
nearby that the power generators no
longer wanted to buy Navajo coal because
states like California had passed laws
saying you know coal is too dirty so
that put the Navajo into a really
difficult situation they were losing
hundreds of jobs and millions upon
millions of dollars in annual royalties
that they had come to rely on to pay for
social services on the reservation and
they really didn't know what to do to
replace this income so along comes ntek
the the Navajo transitional energy
company this is wholly owned by the
Navajo tribe it was created to acquire
mining assets from all over the Navajo
reservation you know an ntek knew that
if it was going to continue to help
support the tribe they needed to acquire
more assets and initially the tribe
thought that ntek could take over old
mines that were on the reservation and
we're in the process of being shut down
but that didn't work out in text
surprised the tribe and surprised the
leaders of the tribe by making this deal
almost a year ago now to acquire three
enormous strip mines far away from the
reservation up in Wyoming and Montana so
overnight they went from owning 1/4
million ton per year mine to owning 450
million ton per year mines they hadn't
shared their plans with the the
leadership of the tribe at all and when
I talk to the company they say well
that's because we're buying these assets
out of bankruptcy court you have to
understand we were
bankruptcy court proceedings yes those
proceedings you're bound by very very
strict and non-disclosure agreements so
as we move forward of course the board
was involved but we were advised by our
legal team that we could not talk
outside of our team unless we had
specific confidentiality agreements or
an autonomous entity of the Navajo
Nation and we're governed by a outside
board that's been given by the nation
the the authority and the
responsibilities that manage the company
and taken the direction that it wished
and so for the past year ntek has been
trying to essentially explain itself and
say you know we we made this move
because we have the best interests of
the tribe at heart we may not be able to
generate jobs on the reservation but
what we do feel an obligation to do is
to generate revenues and profits that we
can send back to the Four Corners region
to the reservation to help support the
tribe and everything that they need to
do and that's especially important right
now because the Navajo have been very
hard hit by kovin 19
there's no other a Native American
company that had been able to pull off
such a large transaction going out
beyond the reservation and spending in
roughly a hundred million dollars to
take on such enormous assets and now all
of a sudden the Navajo are the third
biggest coal miner in all of the United
States the hole that they're trying to
fill right now is about 40 million
dollars a year that's the amount of
money that the tribe was previously
getting from the most recent mine and
power plant that shut down the amount of
coal being burned in the United States
to make electricity right now is lower
than it's been at any time in 42 years
one of the reasons why ntek liked this
acquisition though is because there's
the potential to sell this American
overseas this is not just like a 5 or
10-year project when I talked to CEO
Clark Mosley
he explained that there are such
enormous reserves of coal up there in
the Powder River Basin that they'll be
able to continue mining these reserves
for 20 30 40 years of course whether
they actually do that depends on whether
we continue to use coal there's a lot of
people who would like us to get rid of
it entirely if that happens in the
United States then this could turn out
to be a very bad acquisition for the
Navajo they can get stuck with hundreds
of millions of dollars worth of costs to
clean up these mines and restore the
land there that would be the worst-case
scenario for it it's a big risk that
they're taking
you